yet again sentinels have won a north
american title in valorant and once
again they did it in dominating fashion
there's a lot to talk about playoffs
have given us our three north american
representatives for stage three masses
in berlin which is now right around the
corner for some people though there's a
more pressing question at hand is it
fair to say that we're now living
through the sentinels era
all right we've got a lot to talk about
in today's video and just before we do i
want to remind you guys that we have a
brand new youtube shorts channel you can
find the link to it in the description
box below it's basically where we upload
all of our shorts it's the same content
you know and love but in a much more
bite-sized format go and check it out
and thanks for subscribing as many of
you know sentinels have once again come
out on top in challenger playoffs
cementing themselves as the number one
nac going into stage three masters in
berlin after knocking hundred thieves
down to the lower bracket in a quick 2-0
sentinels once again faced them in the
grand finals now for those of you that
follow the scene closely you'll know
that there's been really no debate that
sentinels is the number one team in
north america and possibly even the
world but the number two spot in north
america has sometimes felt a bit up for
grabs since iceland with teams like 100
thieves envy and except all being in the
conversation so when hundred thief took
down except in the upper bracket
semi-finals and then team envy in the
lower bracket finals one question was
answered 100 thieves are clearly the
number two team in n a but then by
reaching the grand finals to face off
against sentinels once again they had
the chance to prove the narrative wrong
that sentinels are the undisputed kings
of na the only problem is
they kind of are although hundred
thieves fought hard on the second map to
take the series to one all it turned out
to just be a blip in the sentinel show
who seemed like they were just having
fun at times okay being spotted now as
well
oh no no no no no no no no no no i can't
believe you've done this in the grand
final although 100 thieves have proven
that they were worthy finalists the
final outcome of the match felt
inevitable he's falling back onto the
angle he's taken down by still 15
seconds to go for the plan here dapper
that's it sentinels are the north
american challengers champions the best
in the region the best in the world as
the caster said they're the best in the
world right now is that fair to say well
we'll get to that but just before we do
let's look at some of the other valorem
news over the past few days first and
foremost there's north america where
like i said hundred thieves finished
second behind sentinels to claim their
spot in berlin along with the third
place team envy in many ways 100 thieves
securing their first spot at a major
land is bigger news in na than sentinels
going to berlin which let's be honest we
knew was gonna happen they rather
shockingly missed out on iceland despite
their core of old csgo vets in steel
hiko and nitro along with the firepower
of asuna and ethan analysts have wanted
to see how this team's experience would
play out on lan from the moment the
roster was formed
who's been i mean he's been good at
stuff like this many a time he's good
for one the hundreds fury no freaking
way tags up both we'll just take the
fuels in no freaking way captain clutch
does it again he go wins the round for
100 thieves envy are another team that
have been nothing but consistent since
the onset of the valor and champions
tour and we all know that when victor
and crashy show up with their a-game
they can beat anyone even sentinels
zombs
has to have the clutch of his life to
win this one and just look at the
disrespect going from crashes
it's not gonna be enough it's not gonna
be enough and that's gonna be a wrap
envy taking the grand finals these three
teams round out the top three which many
analysts feel is the best the region has
had to offer since iceland now we do
have some idea of who will be joining
them in berlin from around the world
notably vision strikers will be the top
team representing korea now you may
remember them from their insane 102 map
win streak prior to masters 2. the
absolute victors
by and far with a massive undefeated
streak continuing tonight with their
16th championship
also representing korea will be f4q who
didn't actually make it to iceland
representing japan will be the beloved
crazy raccoons who are back once again
after iceland as well as the newcomer
zeta division we also got two of our
four representatives in the european
region in supermassive blaze and ascend
notably fans have been itching to see
cned from ascend face off on the server
against tens for months now they're both
electric in their own right two of the
most highly rated players in the world
who both style on people with jet and
can carry a game on their backs when
their team needs it most i for one will
not be missing that match as for other
takeaways from this weekend we cannot
forget the in-game stuff either for me
steel and hundred thieves really showed
that ko can and will be part of the
professional metagame going forward the
combination of ko and sky are maps like
haven and split allowing you to
virtually hard breach sites with a
flurry of flashes is almost comical at
times we all know that getting
valoranted feeling of trying to hold a
sight and then this happening
dude holy
and well guys the flashes are here to
stay all right with the weekends action
out of the way let's get back to the big
question at hand is this a sentinel's
era or do they still have more to prove
here one of the criticisms here is that
valorum is still pretty new to the
esports scene and lands have been mostly
non-existent in fact in valoran's
19-month competitive history iceland has
been the only major land we've seen sure
sentinels won that whole thing without
dropping a single map and helped to cure
ma as the top region but the lack of
continuous land action due to covid and
how young the scene still is means that
it's difficult to say if this is the
sentinels era or just a really dominant
start from a good team i'm a league of
legends fan someone has to be in league
of legends we get worlds and msi once a
year that's it that's the only time that
we get to see if the speculation about a
team or a region being the best is
actually true but hey some people might
say that an era continues until a team
gets knocked off the throne even if the
next major event is six months down the
line if you use that as your measuring
stick for an era then sure we're
currently living in a time where
sentinels are still the number one team
thanks to their win in iceland the
question is is it fair to say we're then
living through their era remember penta
sports rainbow six siege fans will
remember them as the team that smashed
everyone in the scene for quite a while
for over a year they won almost every
single competition they attended and it
really wasn't that close naturally
there's been comparisons made then
between them and sentinels in valoran
but while penta who were later acquired
by g2 had many competitions to show the
world that that period will forever be
known as their era sentinels just
haven't and while penta made their mark
a few years into siege's competitive
scene where there have been enough time
for things to settle sentinels have done
it during a time where some valor and
teams are still finding their feet on
twitter siege creator get flanked
alluded to this comparison with penta
and g2 saying eventually the competition
will catch up but it looks like it will
take a while so maybe the competition
just hasn't had time to catch up but
does that make it less of a competition
now will we still look back with the
same admiration for sentinels when the
playing field is a bit more level now
this isn't to take away anything from
sentinels clearly they deserve all the
praise they get and hey maybe a year and
a half should be enough time for teams
to get on their level maybe we're not
seeing these guys scramble ahead of the
rest of the pack as the dust settles
maybe sentinels really are just this
good but is it unprecedented in other
esports for two years after the release
of cs go in 2012 ninjas in pyjamas just
dominated the game even though cs go was
new we look back now and say yes
obviously that was the nip era sometimes
we look back at a team dominating an
esport in its early days and say that
was an era sometimes we don't sometimes
we say the game was just new that the
scene hadn't settled yet one of the
concrete ways to figure this out is
tournaments if sentinels win in berlin
and then in champions at the end of the
year then the conversation around their
era will definitely step up a gear
berlin will offer sentinels another
chance to call themselves the best team
in the world and write a new chapter in
what many are already calling the
sentinels era
yeah that should be enough for an emblem
yeah
so
there wasn't
a pickle
[Music]